Speaker 1: We are continuing to learn more
about the I was going to say the investigation,
but the multiple investigations into Republican
Congressman Matt Gates.
And it is every day becoming clearer and clearer
how serious this is.
We learned today that Matt Gates's iPhone
has been seized by federal agents, but not
recently.
It actually was seized some time ago.
This has been going on for a while.
This is very, very serious.
The Huffington Post reporting new reports
on the federal sex trafficking investigation
into Congressman Matt Gates.
Republican of Florida, have revealed more
details about the extent of the probe, including
the seizure of his iPhone by federal agents
over the winter and then associates cooperation
against him.
Since last year.
Gates's cell phone was seized when federal
agents executed a search warrant, citing interviews
with three people who were told of the matter
by the congressman.
Politico was able to report this.
The congressman changed his number late last
year.
His former girlfriend's phone was also reportedly
seized in another development indicating Gates
intensifying predicament predicament.
Gates associate Joel Greenberg has reportedly
been providing information since last year
to investigators, according to The New York
Times.
So that's another piece where we learned,
I guess it was late last week that Joel Greenberg
was now working with investigators.
The New York Times has now learned that Joel
Greenberg has actually been working with investigators
for some time.
Joel Greenberg's lawyer was asked last week,
did your client, Joel Greenberg, introduce
Matt Gates to underage girls?
And there was not a no from Joel Greenberg's
attorney, although he didn't answer much one
way or the other.
Greenberg has said to investigators he and
Gates had sexual encounters with women in
exchange for cash and gifts.
The investigation, of course, is now becoming
increasingly public, but it has been taking
place for some time.
The Justice Department is also said to be
investigating Greenberg's and Gates is involved.
With multiple women who were recruited online
for sex in exchange for cash payments, as
a reminder, the Huffington Post article notes,
it was previously reported Greenberg was likely
on the verge of cooperating with prosecutors
at this point in time.
It is abundantly clear there is also a CNN
report about the details of these very I mean,
anything involving Gates, I call it strange
because Gates is involved, but without going
into too many details that are maybe not relevant
from the standpoint of politics, party goers
and attendees at some of these strange events
have talked about how they would often show
up at an event with Matt Gates.
And there would be cocaine and ecstasy and
sex and all sorts of different things.
And of course, none of these things individually
are really the issue.
The bigger picture here is the idea that there
was some kind of cash for sex prosecution
across state lines, including with minors.
That's really where the bulk of this issue
is.
We don't even really know at this point all
of the other possible crimes that maybe may
be part of this.
But the investigation is ongoing and it's
not looking particularly good for Matt Gates.
Now, it was reported late last week that Matt
Gates had hired one of Donald Trump's various
attorneys to represent him.
I don't know that a Trump attorney is really
going to cut it, given the the depth of what
Matt Gates appears to be involved in here.
Matt Gates approach basically for the two
weeks since this broke, has been to minimize
the seriousness of the investigation and to
suggest that the investigation is merely politically
motivated and and nothing else at this point.
The investigations are so wide ranging.
They've been going on for so long and they
involve so many different people that it would
be a very silly way to carry out a political
hit job against Matt Gates.
You wouldn't do it this way.
You wouldn't do it in a way where there is
so much involving other people, other already
plea deals that, for example, Joel Joel Greenberg,
already accepting a plea deal is just not
the way that it would work.
This also, I think it's important to mention,
sheds new light onto the pardon that Matt
Gates supposedly asked Donald Trump for.
Now, I told you last week that Donald Trump
has denied having been asked for a pardon
by Matt Gates, although the sourcing on the
stories claiming Gates asked for the pardon
are very good.
My best explanation for how this could all
be true, as I mentioned earlier this week,
is that Matt Gates has one of his associates
sort of feel out a pardon with people around
Donald Trump.
The people around Trump could easily say Gates
is not getting a pardon.
It never actually gets to Trump.
It never actually gets to the point of Donald
Trump saying no.
It's it's merely made clear between staffers
that it's not going to happen.
Seems a completely plausible way in which
basically all of the reporting is true, at
least in some way, a very possible outcome
here.
We're all talking about will Gates resign?
Will he be arrested?
Will he be charged?
Is Gates going to go to prison with a lot
of these guys?
And it is guys that it happens with.
A possible outcome is Gates has some kind
of come to Jesus moment, he resigns, or maybe
not, but he says he's entering some kind of
program, 12 step, who knows?
Sex Addicts Anonymous, Alcoholics Anonymous.
He's going to work on himself.
Maybe he doesn't even resign, but maybe he
does.
And then he comes back and says he found Jesus
and he's been saved.
And all of this stuff, it seems completely
plausible to me that that's the direction
it could go.
Of course, everyone is innocent until proven
guilty.
Matt Gates hasn't even been charged at this
point.
And I have no you know, there I'll get emails
saying, David, how dare you say Gates should
go to prison?
I haven't said that once.
The first step would be, let's see if Gates
is charged hasn't happened yet.
If he is, then we will go to the next step.